[Music]
here's your money briefing for Wednesday
April 19th I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
financial advisors have long recommended
a 60 40 approach to investing 60 in
stocks and 40 in bonds but sharp Market
declines last year pushed that strategy
out the window now in 2023 it's back on
the table for investors to consider Wall
Street Journal Market supporter harika
Singh joins us to explain why so hardika
with the exception of last year why has
the 60 40 strategy worked so well for
investors investors have relied on the
60 40 strategy for decades financial
advisors across the country tell
Americans planning for retirement that
it is mostly a Surefire way to get
steady cash flow from 1988 to 2022 35
years the strategy has earned an average
of 9.3 percent annually that's a lot all
right and so why did that strategy not
work in 2022 the market faced a lot of
challenges last year very few things
work stocks suffered Bonds were also
down oil prices were all over the place
and 60 40 strategy was just one of the
many things that didn't exactly work
last year it fell because the Federal
Reserve was aggressively raising
interest rates and that brought down
bonds at the same time as stocks those
simultaneous or you can say tandem
losses were really hurtful to the
strategy which depends on 60 of its
allocation made in stocks and the other
40 percent made in bonds to further put
that into numbers last year the S P 500
which is 500 stocks in the US it
finished down about 15 percent and that
includes dividends and then in addition
to that bonds which were supposed to
sort of help your portfolio hold up in
value a little bit better they suffered
their worst bear Market in decades all
right so let's focus on 2023 what is it
about the market this year that makes
the 60 40 strategy attractive again it's
it's all about the FED investors are
betting now on the Federal Reserve
pivoting from their aggressive interest
rate campaign and pairing back some of
their hikes essentially and the recent
banking crisis has supercharged those
bets because people now think we're
going to have a recession with tighter
lending standards coming into place a
portfolio with 60 of its money invested
in U.S stocks and 40 percent in the
Bloomberg U.S aggregate Bond index has
gained 5.9 percent this year but is this
a sure thing in 2023 it seems like the
FED is always full of surprises and kind
of catches the market by surprise plus
we keep hearing that stocks are
expensive and might have room to come
down could that impact the effectiveness
of 60 40. absolutely the economy
continues to be strong and the FED has
set so many times that no we're not
going to be like looking at cutting
already we still want to tame inflation
which is why they had started this
aggressive interest rate campaign in the
first place case and it seems like
investors are sort of in a different
mindset they think that the FED is
bluffing so that's why it feels like
there's this disconnect between the two
parties essentially and stocks yes are
still very expensive by historical value
so yeah it seems like we're going to
have to wait and see what happens with
regards to stocks and bonds and maybe 60
40 continues to make a comeback this
year but we've also talked on the show
about how more investors are keeping a
sizable percentage of their portfolio in
cash to take advantage of the strong
returns how would that affect 60 40. a
lot of investors have started going into
cash not just retail but also
institutional and the main reason behind
that is number one it's super safe
compared to going into stocks especially
if you're worried about greater losses
and then number two is the return a lot
of money market funds right now are
giving you five percent you can easily
go to your nearest bank and get a CD and
get 5 percent which is much safer than
investing in stocks and also returning
more than bonds at the moment
so as an investor if you're getting
slightly higher than that five percent
on your 60 40 strategy would you really
want to take that risk to go out of your
cash investment and go into 60 40. not
really a lot of people will not probably
want to do that they'd want to stick to
their cash Holdings all right that's
markets reporter hardika Singh thanks so
much for being with us and that's your
money briefing I'm J.R Whalen for the
Wall Street Journal
[Music]
thank you